[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous connaissez l'histoire de
toto aux toilettes
non c'est normal il a fermé la clé à clé
de l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
il passe à côté bravo cherrybomb quelle
est la personnalité qui vous a le plus
dégoûtés dans votre carrière
la personnalité qui m'a le plus dégoûtés
j'ai des vieux souvenirs mais le vrai
dégoût pour l'âme pour le physique il
est là c'est mathieu de leur arrivée
même joey starr & home était devant moi
mais tu restes armée pas hypocrite alors
c'est vrai la question qui tue pour
matière de leur route s'étire à monsieur
de leurs mots pour quelles propositions
professionnelles quitteriez vous
immédiatement touche pas à mon poste
pour animer on n'est pas couché à la
place de leurs enquêtes encore très bons
mais qui va forcément venir avec le
temps
sur france 2 bon écoute et on est
tranquille et patrie de nous qu'il n'y
avait eu ni buzz combien de temps vous
comptez encore faire de la télé ça
commence à faire un sacré beau mais je
vais vous demander conseil mais ce qu en
fait depuis beaucoup plus longtemps que
moi
oh la la
à eux
allez
[Musique]